- How have you been
keeping yourselves busy?
'Cause I know a lot of people have,
while being stuck at home
have started new things.
I have toddlers so I have started,
I never thought I'd be one
of those adults coloring
in those adult coloring books,
well little did I know,
the pandemic would bring that to light
because I'm done drawing Jasmine.
I can't color another Jasmine,
so I've started coloring.
(laughing)
Have y'all started doing anything?
- Maisie?
- Joey, you've been killing it.
I've been watching her, so jealous, go on.
- I started doing dioramas.
I've taken-
- What?
- It's like, so you know
like little house models.
Like little models of mini scapes.
So I make a mini library,
last month that took
me three weeks to make
and that was so
- Can I see it?
- much fun.
Yeah, I have a photo of it.
- Okay.
- It's was so fun and
I just loved it so much
and I just bought a little kit to make
a diorama coffee shop, so that, you know.
This is my library.
- Oh my gosh.
- What!
- How!
- Oh my gosh!
Well okay, I haven't done that
but my kids have just
recently gotten into Legos.
They're four and six so I've
started building little things
like that, but that is crazy hard!
- Oh my gosh, it was so hard.
It took me, and the instructions,
they're great but
they're kind of more like
a loose suggestion of how to make it.
(laughing)
I'm like, I don't know what I'm doing
but it was so fun.
Maisie, what about you?
- Well, it's kinds of funny
'cause since I was about
four till 15, I had this
dream of having a farm
and being a farmer and it
was just like this obsession,
this dream of like, I'm just
gonna grow my own produce,
raise my own animals.
So I was like, right, I've got some time,
I'm gonna start some gardening.
I'm gonna do this.
So I planted spinach, I planted okra,
I did zucchini,
- Wow!
- vegetables, everything,
and nothing grew.
- Oh no!
- Oh,
I was just about to say,
I love okra.
(laughing)
- The only thing that
grew was my sunflower
'cause apparently it's
a weed, I didn't know.
- And that's my favorite flower.
- Exactly, so I had
this one little flower.
I named it Kelly-
- Oh my gosh, that's amazing!
- I will persevere.